do you want to do the awkward pause now
i mean it is about time no no let's not
do the awkward you don't want to do the
awkward pass
it's so awkward
what do you want to do then i want to
feel
comfortable yeah come over here then
hey
my arms don't work but i got a lot of
spirits
boy sometimes here at cbs i wish the
sound wasn't working
this is the problem
hey do we have some [ __ ] security in
this building or do i have to come over
and kick this guy down
i just touch your boobs
roll that back i didn't see that
roll it back
[Applause]
roll it back
[Applause]
stop stop stop stop stop it
oh my heaven stop sit stop it i don't
know what to do stop it right now
absolutely
wait
i wasn't gonna see anything
i'm sorry
[Applause]
i'll kick your ass out of here too
it's not a debate it's a debate between
us you're in the audience audience comes
from the latin to listen
what's going on here
i immediately knew in this situation
that it was wrong and it wasn't a
spectacle or just you know it's
actually someone's
emotions you know that i stepped on it
was very
it was just it was rude period and
you know i'd like to be able to
apologize to her in person
and you know i wanted to
let me ask something i was fortunate
enough to meet your mom and talk with
your mom a number of years ago
what do you think she would have said
about this
um
would she be disappointed in this would
she give you a lecture
yeah and the harmonica just really kind
of just got into my blood yeah it's good
do you play yourself and i no i just got
one though and i want to learn so maybe
you can be my teacher no no i can't
maybe i could is that the sore leg yes
the doctor told me to elevate it so here
we go
no
this is the late late show right
it is now yeah
oh there's a horse in the corner
the horse looks like he's doing
something else it's very late lately oh
yeah no yes that's how he passes the
time do you have kleenex next wait wait
[Music]
what's going on that's jeff
where am i
who's that guy
that guy one thing i'm not gay anymore
yeah
jerry was there ever any doubt in your
mind that you would have any difficulty
uh wrestling uh
andy
not really no doubt at all you see
i don't i don't want to sit out here and
pretend that i'm friends with this guy
because i think he's a wimp
you see when i think when andy was born
his father wanted a boy and his mother
wanted a girl and they were both
satisfied
even you asked me last time i was on
your show if i if i was uh gonna have a
lawsuit and i could have sued you i
could have sued you for everything
you're worth and i didn't because that's
i'm not that kind of a guy yeah you know
what uh what kind of a guy are you
no
you're not about you you're obviously
over
[Applause]
i don't think president bush brought
down the world trade center
and cows disagree with me
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
so
oh no what's up my bar just broke
i just inhaled and went knock
you should have gotten the 12 million
bra that's what
[Applause]
yeah i see something yeah
it's a bad break yeah yeah
i got it here it is jay here is it over
here
marty how you making out well i'm doing
fine rodney's got his hands
[Music]
uh i know you didn't want to come on
here for the longest time so why finally
after uh nearly four and a half years
did you decide to come on
i don't know i i thought it was one
reason but i'm sure that couldn't what
is the reason you thought it was i
wanted to pay my hotel bill
okay so that you thought that was one
reason but of course that's not really
the reason why what was the re i mean
you must have had a change of heart
about something
no actually
i don't know because i thought that i
would never want to do this show with
you now why
now let's let's
explore this a little why
because you thought i was uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you afraid of
well i was gonna go with flying but i
think i'll go with um girls over 12.
[Applause]
[Music]
harder harder yes
tension i'm squeezing you
i have so much tension right now this is
unbelievable the next thing is an inhale
of breath oh my god and smell my breath
okay kill it
i'm sure jen gets it and you know what
she probably didn't
somebody phone on yeah
get out
get
out turn that phone off now
so
ma'am
would you like me to do a dance for you
what
hi paul
okay
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
and uh we've done some weird things on
the show uh we once filled a a container
uh with four thousand pounds of baked
beans and made kids dive into it which
was really great yeah i wish i'd seen
that you would
now you say you you make the kids i mean
you force the child you hold the child's
head under the base and then throw them
out and then we have uh and i'm talking
about we were neat in his fridge
i just said that because your back is to
me and i i was just talking to her back
no no i could talk to you too thank you
watch out he's got scissors he's got
scissors no i was just wondering who
told you that because
my wife tells me that often she says
good morning i'm still married as a
matter of fact yes will you
[Applause]
wow okay yeah so anyway we were talking
about uh being a neatness fanatic yeah
it's talking about being an english
fanatic but you started out as a
magician
what's this that's all right thank you
about a week and a half later it came
but
there we go
[Applause]
you